hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent opening trap to share with you
this was played at the 1958-59 US
Championship on the white end Bobby
fiser playing against Samuel
RFI this is a 15-year-old Fisher he won
this event became
champ beat out second play Samuel
rashevsky by one point this was
rashevsky's only loss of the event
so you might as well say this game here
won fer the
championship we have an accelerated
Dragon fers reply Bishop
B3 instead if White
Castles this would allow the center fork
trick capture on e4 and then D5 this is
Black's way to get the piece back this
helps us understand why the bishop takes
a step back no more Center fork
trick the reply Now by Revy
985 important moment in the game I
wonder if you can spot Fisher's
continuation feel free to pause the
video and give this one some time I will
be devoting some time to
it
okay before I share the continuation
what I'd like to do is share how I think
an experienced player may see this
position what squares light up in the
mind of an experienced player and why
those squares light
up first of all we have B3 and C4 these
are squares that the Knight Now controls
from
A5 additionally there are the squares D4
and D5 these are squares the Knight no
longer
controls this helps draw our attention
to what new possibilities are available
to White is there way to take advantage
of the weak of the last
move White's Pawn can advance in the
center and challenge the king Knight
where would it go if it goes to the edge
it can be trapped with G4 what other
options does it have it have to go in
reverse and when it goes in reverse we
would have the other Center squares
lighting up it no longer controls D5 and
E4 anything else yes another key note
when the Knight is on E8 there's a
disconnect between the major pieces and
the black queen is all of a sudden
unprotected the continuation in this
game
E5 the best continuation for black at
this stage not a pleasant one but this
is considered best to take the bishop
and allow this imbalance the two minor
pieces versus The Rook this Knight will
be tracked soon enough in this game
though the Knight immediately goes back
and now we have this winning tactical
shot Bishop takes
F7 this takes full advantage of the
unprotected
Queen what are Black's options take with
the Rook take with the king or run in
the corner regardless of what move is
played the continuation will be the same
and that is Knight
E6
The Queen Is Dead no safe squares these
two are covered this one is
covered and what are Black's
options um if you take with the King
it's going to lead to
mate what does that mate look like Queen
D5 G4 with check gladly pitch a pawn to
open a file for another piece and if you
go here that's mate and if the King goes
to any of the H file
squares you could play Queen G2 and soon
enough it's going to be mate on one of
these squares in just a couple moves at
most all right the move played in this
game Pawn takes Knight it's already over
Queen is a goner a winning tactical shot
I'll just be playing through the rest of
this game and making some light notes in
general want to trade down of the
material it's a queen versus two minor
pieces and we're going to see that
whenever black tries to get in a
coordinated position it's broken
down so improving the Knight improving
the Knight further E6 is in the
crosshairs some control of the Knight
activate the Rook get some trades in
here pinpoint the weaknesses E6 Under
Fire it's defended but Now The Rook is
harassed a bunch of times and where do
you go at this stage if you go to one of
these two Knight G5 would Target the
rook and
H7 so the E Pawn in
short is now a goner with
check and from here we get some trades
in with the fork no more dark Square
Bishop this is a stable piece but not
for long in comes the B Pawn the Knight
Will soon have to find a new Square A6
is not stopping B5 because another
unprotected piece in the position B5
would still hit Rooks are now connected
Knight's driven back reposition The Rook
trying to get to the prized seventh rank
A6
B6 Bishop E4 and Bishop C6 second time
now we have this piece a minor piece
minor piece I should say on C6 it's
eliminated give back some material break
things down and with that there's now a
passer that immediately
advances in the game The Rook goes to
B8 if you try to attack the pawn while
still defending A6 there's the Tactical
shot Queen takes rook and then you
promote get a new Queen with check and
take some more material
all right Rook B8 Queen takes a black
ends up tracking down the B Pawn but
this means there's going to be more
exchanges Queen A8 final move of the
game black
resigns there's no hope here what do you
try check King H2 you have to find a
safe Square for your knight maybe you go
here the plan push your a pawn best case
scenario for black Maybe
you're able to sacrifice the Knight for
the a pawn but in that
position uh yeah The Rook is going to be
no match for the queen so what did you
think of this one did you find fiser
winning tactical sequence out of the
opening the idea I had with sharing this
game this opening trap is to draw your
attention to what pieces do and no
longer do after a move it's it's not
about this one trap it's not like hey if
you're ever in this exact position
sometime do this
no I think focusing on the key
differences in the position as a piece
moves from one square to the next is an
excellent blueprint for finding best
continuations anyhow Feel Free as usual
to leave any feedback to this video in
the comment section below I hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care
bye